ce programme vous est présenté par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale you
to want squeeze aujourd'hui on se trouve
sur un jeu honda cambrioler une maison
on s'est encore fait baiser ces partis
allez on va voir ce qu'on va devoir
cambriolé j'ai pressé et un space to
start oui c'est fait on peut courir on
peut être un talent très bien et ben
voilà
et là hop on a la liste alors une
guitare paintings on est dans la merde
où je vais me servir de l'eau je viens
pas pour quand mollet mais juste
pourquoi un verre d'eau je risque qu'est
ce qui s'est passé là y'a un truc qui va
pas et que cette liste mais watts mais
alors cet homme des tableaux très à
gauche veut carrément voler un tableau
qui vaut un euro marché et sud n'ont en
réalité je vais mal à le poser juste
comme ça si l'essence n'est pas du tout
vrai on voit [ __ ] les maisons pour
respecte oublier que je passais par là
mon nom watts mais qu'est ce qui se
passe je ne veux pas ma couplé avec
cette lampe qu'on arrête ça tout de
suite et on ya quelqu'un la discrétion
du corps roller jiwar libock là ça a
changé j'ai dû relancer je pense que
j'ai bugué je me sentis agressés en
ouvrant ses portes
micron wave c'est ça un micro ondes oh
[ __ ] quand ils volent le truc qui fait
pas semblant mais quinté qui sait que
cette maison totalement immense ya pas
un truc à progresser qu'est-ce qui fait
bruisser salah
auj comme la professionnelle depuis
actuellement deux minutes
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est ce que
c'est que ça la cafat à aller on apprend
aux 120 ta gueule et d'aia mais tu vas
la fermer
mais c'est quoi cette horloge mais
quelle dans l'auge qui sonne à 3h du mat
comme ça pas là un lecteur de dvd non ça
c'est une ps3 meert
après on va jouer à cache-cache ans ramé
ohlala je rigole on ouvre la porte de la
chambre se tromper de choc qui a une
liasse débuta le mec c'est un avare
quand le mec qui habitent ici le break à
des déblayages de billettes suivant
partout dans la maison
aoka ou au chaos rien du tout d'ailleurs
c'est une prévision totalement nul au
nom ils viennent de rentrer faut que je
me cache faut que je me cache doit pas
qu'à doit pas car on sait qu'on va se
faire griller à la juve le placard il ya
un gros bug qui fait coucou
revenons à notre cambriolage la temps
était un truc que finalement apprendre
pourquoi mais arrête avec pigasse de
billets ben dhia taha aux cambrioleurs
mec métro chelou que je vais mettre des
liasses de billets absolument partout
dans ma maison
vous l'avez vu jouer ici à l'homme vers
l'homme en vert mais voilà on cambriole
la maison de robin des bois mais tout
est normal dans ce [ __ ] de jeu xulu
mais ça n'a pas de sens mais cet homme
est somnambule
mais je crois qu'en fait il est
complètement buggé j'espère qu'à pas me
voir discrétion qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ici
quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ça au
mouloudia alléluia j'ai skié mais cet
homme un problème non mais sans déconner
pour que lui mettre un coup de chaise ou
et sos me vois tu le mans vers le mec au
vol une maison mais il ya juste une
liste de choses à apprendre à se dire
qu'il ya une [ __ ] de télé qui vous un
max de thune mais il y en a rien à
[ __ ]
lui ce qu'il veut c'est une tablette
l'eee tablet est un lecteur dvd
lorsqu'il n'existe plus depuis 1938
avant jésus-christ à l'otan de bonsoir
elle vous crois que je suis en train de
cowboy votre maison monsieur a peut-être
ne pouvez-vous pas me voir ni me
répondre parce que vous n'avez pas dieu
et bakbou rhj
et dans ce cas c'est votre problème pour
ok c'est réveiller la [ __ ] c'est bruce
lee et casse toi oh la la ensuite
incroyable dans la maison tin tin tin
tin tin tin tin tin dans le frigo d'un
frigo on peut pas aller on va dans le
mec mais c'est carrément un emploi et
quoi il se mêle à ace dit il ya des
choses sur ta liste a cambriolé keynes
ou en bas et tu ne pourras pas passer
parce que je te bloque avec mes grosses
fesses de beat & bim ma palette
cambriolage ou pire un tableau comme ça
chez lui et d'une espèce de abbas et sa
femme la femme au but
la voici allez dégage femmes au but je
vole des toilettes voilà je suis
quelqu'un qui adore les toilettes jouent
alors volé une poubelle la chose à plus
est par contre cette liste de courses
elles peuvent regarder je sais pas si
c'est une liste de courses ou si c'est
un ange gardien qui joue enfin bref que
de la merde ok donc en fait je pense que
quand l'horloge sonne ça doit vouloir
dire attention il arrive d'ici peu de
temps
ainsi nous fait le coup qui l'a fait
juste avant je vous promets un mois j'ai
fait moi je moi je suis je ne sais pas
me battre
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de l'arrivée d'un grand temps la
voiture ils arrivent à se poser là il va
ferrailler madame ça casse toi de table
de merde ont la dent oui oh merde au
coffre il est fermé oh oui la caméra
digitale
elle est à nous
où mais m mais les tableaux un problème
d'enjeux [ __ ] de bordel de merde allez
vite vite vite il est arrivé voilà up
essais il sera pas pourquoi il ya une
chaise mais y en avait non il met
vraiment de la thune partout dans sa
maison pu tomber à ils arrivent ils
arrivent ils arrivent ils arrivent ils
arrivent ils arrivent à londres
alors j'espère que ce n'est pas sa
chambre au pire je proposerai un deal à
l'amiable je l'aiderai à la rangée parce
que là cette chambre et dans le bordel
on voit ce que sont pas car je trouvais
pas d'hommes vers l'horizon
nous pouvons y aller moi je descends
déjà de base
logiquement il est allé se coucher cet
homme ce n'est pas moi tu ne m'as pas vu
je suis trop rapide pour toi ah et on
tombe sur un mec qui fait des [ __ ]
d'insomnie quoi ils pourraient pas juste
aller se coucher faire vas-y voir le
mois tout je m'en fous n'ont
certainement rien volé un meuble ikea je
pense que du monde s'emballe et steq oui
oh non non vous savez ce que ça veut
dire
on va tenter un truc et attention vous
êtes prêts on va mettre la petite
musique la plus connue lors d'une course
poursuite
c'est parti
est ce que l'homme hobbit va nourrir ce
placard pour nous faire un petit coucou
à ses bons et je peux marcher tout âge
me suis enfui oh merde il est au micro
ondes à ouallam équivalent à vic route
[ __ ] mais je m'en remettrai jamais
alors moi j'ai le choix il ya un lingot
d'or à 1 micron 17 personnes à moi je
vais plutôt partir sur micro ondes
puisque bon j'adore le les plats les
panaris lac ou trois zones
mais tout change de place à chaque fois
en fait c'est super fort comme jeu sous
les oreillers là tous les clients
choqués de kashebere le tableau là y'a
pas un truc galt quoi fallait que je
voyais ce tableau dégueulasse ah oui
portrait d'une fille fallait que je le
vole quand même temps vers l'est c'est
carrément dans le coffre faut pas que je
vole ce cette coupe elle pendant que j'y
suis d'une valeur de j'ai craché un truc
mon dieu tu es moi y'a rien dans ses
tiroirs eux il ya landi super génial
il ya bien un truc ici dans les tiroirs
au cède 2,7 un v2 et v3
on a un max de thune je vous dis en mon
coeur m'a vite j'ai peur cet homme verne
fait très très peur il est extrêmement
fondre ce qui implique d'une gestuelle
oui le livre des gros je ne sais pas ce
que c'est qu'un round qu'elle dans ce
placard à la fameuse liasses de billets
à l est pour nous un rat juan horrach
wine regardez regardez regardez sûrement
spectaculaire les doigts se dire les
lumières de ma maison ne marche plus bon
bah c'est l'heure d'aller se coucher
et là vous allez tous me dire en
commentaire un round c'est ça et je vais
faire face faute fois dise je m'en bats
les couilles
as tu me suis un a tu me suis largement
by step j'ai tout ce que je voulais le
voler escape
on a volé en l'espace de quatre minutes
et 35 secondes l'équivalent de 38 $ de
l'eau nous sommes riches
à bientôt pour voler d'autres choses
bien oui c
c'est pas mal pas mal du tout et là
bingo je suis trop content mon papa est
fière de moi
mais qu'est ce que c'est que toutes ces
vidéos complètement bizarre mon fils est
un dangereux psychopathe 1